brought to you by The Witcher Wild Hunt
available May nineteenth it's a new week
and that means the critically acclaimed
Witcher 3 makes its long-awaited debut
the ninth game to obtain the coveted
score of 10 on gamespot com kevin van
noord states where the witcher 2
sputtered into a halt the witcher 3 is
always in a crescendo crafting battle
scenarios that constantly one up the
last until you reach the explosive
finale and recover in the glow of the
game's quiet day new muah but while the
grand clashes are captivating it's the
moment when you drink with the local
clans and bask in a tow lariat song that
are truly inspiring we don't say it's
essential for nothing you can pick up
the witcher 3 wild hunt on the 19th did
you know that there are other games
coming out this week well there are
swords and soldiers gets a sequel this
week coming exclusively to Wii U if you
remember the original RTS you'll be glad
to hear the colorful witty side scroller
hasn't lost its humor aside red beard
and his ambitious group of round rowdy
vikings are still at your side ready to
destroy some buildings and stuff protect
the sheep on the 21st also this week
life is strange gets its third episode
adding a bit more complexity to an
already stressful teenage girl's life
max can rewind time but can she make
sure to only use her powers for good
sometimes even good intentions lead down
a dark path and that's a lot to have on
your mind while you're studying for the
SATs part 3 of 5 drops on the 19th
hyperdimension neptunia you action
unleashed makes its way to North America
and Europe on Vita this week in this
game play clip you can check out the
interchangeable character system and
costume damage complete with minimally
covered ladies or the costume brake
system complete with minimally covered
ladies and quest system complete when
you fulfill the clear conditions
your battle with difficult clothing
begins on the 19th finally I just can't
let you go without mentioning this
absolutely ridiculous Mad Max simulator
called carmageddon drive tiny Hot Wheels
styled cars through loops and into cows
and humans to prove something to someone
you're extreme after all health look at
the early access page it's in all caps
it doesn't get more extreme than this
race for freedom on the 21st for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week
you